Russian tanks that cost over a million
dollars are being taken out by Cheap
consumer style drones
like this one that cost a few hundred
dollars
since the Ukrainian counter-offensive
began military analysts say there's been
a dramatic increase in Ukraine's use of
fpv or first-person view drones with
most Ukrainian battalions using these
drones to execute Kamikaze style attacks
on Russian tanks troop positions and
other large-scale weapons
the aim is twofold to make the military
less dependent on weapons from Western
countries
and to operate cheaply
[Music]
The Wall Street Journal collected dozens
of attack videos from Ukrainian drone
teams and spoke to analysts from Jane's
intelligence to break down how these
attacks were executed
Kamikaze drones must get very close to a
Target and remain undetectable
to execute an attack like this fpv drone
Pilots work in teams to identify targets
and get into position to strike
the team usually includes a driver to
get to the attack location and two drone
Pilots one for the attack or Kamikaze
drone and one for a reconnaissance drone
the optimal flight distance for Missions
is roughly one to two miles to the
Target
but they can launch from as far as 7
miles
one way they evade detection is by using
low quality cameras on fpvs the signals
these cameras transmit are less likely
to be scrambled by Russian electronic
warfare systems
before launching The Operators attach
explosives to the Kamikaze drone with
tape and Hardware
the attack drone operator wears a
virtual reality style headset to control
the Drone
after launching a reconnaissance drone
looks for the Target in this footage
from the zaparita region near the city
of orihiv
it's a Russian truck
ukrainians targeted it because it was
carrying ammunition to Russian troops
the attack drone follows the truck as it
turns and crashes into it detonating its
payload
when striking a supply truck like this a
drone pilot will aim for the cabin to
take out the driver
the strategy is similar when targeting
tanks
the most vulnerable spot on a tank is
its engine compartment located here on
the rear side
drone Pilots often aim for them as in
this attack from behind
the drones strike the weakest points on
tanks and heavy machinery like these
infantry fighting Vehicles here the open
hatch is a vulnerability the pilot
likely noticed
the pilot appears to hit the turret
where some of the vehicles crew sit an
ammunition is stowed
here a Kamikaze drone strikes a Russian
truck that lays landmines on these
trucks Pilots Target the mine modules
deterring these trucks is key as
minefields have been a major obstacle in
Ukraine's fight to regain territory
the failure rate of missions can be high
according to Ukrainian units we spoke to
Russian Firepower can knock these drones
out of the sky if discovered as shown by
this near Miss
about a hundred Ukrainian companies
manufacture fpvs 40 of which receive
government contracts most of the parts
these companies use come from China and
are becoming difficult to source
[Music]
Ukraine's use of these DIY style weapons
is rapidly evolving
and now Russia is catching up